conditional PDFs share most of the
properties of conditional pmfs all facts
for the discrete case have continuous
analogs the intuition is more or less
the same although it is much easier to
grasp in the discrete case for example
we have seen this version of the total
probability theorem there is a
continuous analogue in which we replace
sums by integrals and we replace pmf's
by pdfs the proof of this fact is
actually pretty simple by the
multiplication rule the integrand here
is just the joint PDF of x and y and we
know that if we take the joint PDF and
integrate with respect to one variable
then we recover the PDF the marginal PDF
of the other random variable so this is
one theorem that extends to the
continuous case moving along we have
defined the conditional expectation in
this manner in the discrete case and we
define it similarly for the continuous
case so actually here we now have a new
definition this definition is also
consistent with the definition of the
expectation of a continuous random
variable the expected value of a
continuous random variable is the
integral of x times a density except
that here we live in a conditional
universe where we're conditioning on
this event and therefore we need to use
the corresponding conditional PDF
finally we have the total expectation
theorem in the discrete case and there
is the obvious analogue in the
continuous case where we are using an
integral and a density the
interpretation is that we consider all
possibilities for Y under each
possibility of Y we find the expected
value of x and then we weigh those
different possibilities according to the
corresponding values of the density so
we're taking a weighted average of these
conditional expectations to obtain the
overall expectation of the random
variable X
the derivation of this fact is maybe a
little instructive because it uses
various facts that we have in our hands
so let's see how to derive it we start
from this expression in the right hand
side and we will show that it is equal
to the expected value of X the
expression on the right hand side is
equal to the following it's the integral
of the density of Y and then inside here
we have the conditional expectation
which is defined this way so we just
plug in the definition
and then what we do is we take this term
and move it inside the integral which we
can do because this integral is with
respect to X and therefore this is like
a constant
and we also interchange the order of
integration now the inner integration is
with respect to Y as far as Y is
concerned this term X is a constant so
we can take it and move it outside this
first integral and place it out there so
this term disappears and goes out there
what do we have here
this part by the previous fact the total
probability theorem is just the density
of X so we're left with the integral of
x times the density of X DX and this is
the expected value of X finally we have
various forms of the expected value rule
which barely deserve writing down
because they're exactly what you might
expect consider for example an
expression such as this one the expected
value of a function of the random
variable X but conditioned on the value
of the random variable Y how do we
calculate this quantity
well the expected value rule tells us
that we should integrate G of x times
the density of X but because here we
live in a conditional universe we should
actually use the corresponding
conditional PDF of X and there are many
other versions of the expected value
rule any version that we have seen for
the discrete case has also a continuous
analogue which looks about the same
except that we integrate and that we use
densities